[MUSIC PLAYING]
EDINA BAKOS: Hi.
Welcome to CloudAir, live
webinars from Google Cloud.
We hold these live webinar
sessions every Tuesday.
Today, we are going to talk
about GDPR and G Suite.
My name is Edina Bakos,
and I am a privacy program
manager in Google Cloud.
I'm based in
Sunnyvale, California,
and I work very
closely with engineers
on some of our data
protection programs.
You can ask questions
anytime on the platform.
We have Googlers standing
by to answer them.
And also, we will
have a Q&A at the end.
So let's get started.
So first, when I was asked
to talk about the GDPR,
I was thinking,
oh man, I probably
can talk about
the GDPR for days.
But I know we have
limited time today,
so I decided to focus on
certain aspects of the GDPR,
which is how it
relates to Google Cloud
and, specifically,
how we in G Suite
can support our customers
in GDPR compliance.
So first of all, I
just wanted to give
a general high-level
overview of the GDPR.
What is the GDPR?
The GDPR stands for the General
Data Protection Regulation
in Europe.
And this is, by far, the most
significant data protection
legislation that came out from
Europe in the last 20 years.
And the last one, of course,
the European Data Protection
Directive 20 years ago--
and 20 years ago, it
was a very different era
in terms of the internet.
Internet was not
as commonly used,
and especially, there was not
so much personal data on it.
Some other big differences
between the European Data
Protection Directive
from 20 years ago
and the General Data
Protection Regulation
is that the directive
is a directive, which
means that it directed
member states to pass
their own privacy legislation.
The result was similar laws
but somewhat of a patchwork,
and that mades compliance very
challenging from customers
and providers alike.
And the GDPR intends to
harmonize these laws,
and it's also a
regulation, which
means that it has a
direct effect on the law.
So it's legally binding,
and member states
don't have to pass
separate legislation.
And of course, it
means to be much more
convenient for customers
and providers alike.
Probably the most important
thing about the GDPR,
that it enhances
data subject rights.
It's building on existing
data protection principles,
such as data minimization,
storage limitation, purpose
limitation.
What does it mean?
It means that when
a company collects
data for a specific
purpose, it should
be processed for only that
purpose and only for a time
period necessary.
And of course, there are other
data protection principles,
such as lawfulness, fairness,
transparency, data accuracy,
integrity, and so forth.
We find all of these data
protection principles
in the GDPR and the
data subject rights
built on these principles.
For example, data
integrity accuracy
means that data subject
rights have a right
to request to rectify
from companies,
to store the data that--
from the companies
about the data
that they store about them--
so right to rectification,
right to access,
right to restrict
for data procession,
and also data deletion.
The GDPR also introduces
two new rights.
One is data portability, and the
other is right to [INAUDIBLE]..
And I will talk about these
data subject rights later.
And as part of the enhanced
data subject rights,
the GDPR also further expands
the international data transfer
protection, which means
that if data flows outside
of the European
Union, companies have
to make sure that that data
has the adequate level of data
protection.
And the GDPR also lists
additional mechanisms.
Compared to the previous
one, for example,
where there are
contract clauses,
now we also have
bilingual [INAUDIBLE]
and other certification
mechanisms
that companies can use.
All right, so what are
the five key things
I wanted to talk about today in
terms of the regulation of GDPR
and Google Cloud?
Well, the first key difference
is that now the GDPR also
applies to cloud providers.
It means that it's not
only the customer, you,
but us, Google Cloud, are also
responsible for our compliance.
Second, I also wanted to
talk about the sub-processor
and what does it
mean in terms of--
in our obligations for the GDPR,
that we work for sub-processors
to process customer data.
I'm going to extend
a little bit more
about the extended
data subject rights.
I'm going to select
two rights, and I'm
going to demonstrate
how we can support
the customers [INAUDIBLE]
subject have requested
them regarding their data.
And fourth, I want to talk
about the incredible high fines
that the GDPR
introduced, which can
be as high as 20 million euros,
or 4% of the annual turnover.
And finally, I wanted to
talk about GDPR and security,
and I also wanted to
showcase some of the security
product features
and configurations
that we offer in G Suite that
can be helpful with compliance.
So number one is
data processors.
As I mentioned this
first point, now the GDPR
also applies to cloud
providers, to us.
So what does it mean?
Maybe you have
heard the terms data
controller and data processors.
The GDPR reintroduces
these terms.
They were already present in
the European Data Protection
Directive, but now the GDPR
further qualifies and explains
their meaning.
Data controllers are
you, the customers
who are primarily responsible
for data processing.
What does it mean?
That you are the one who
determines the purposes
and means of data
processing, based
on the wording of the law.
In other words, it means
that the customer, the data
controller, is the one
who decides on the why
and how on the data processing.
And we, as data processors, are
the ones who process data only
based on your instructions and
on behalf of the controller.
So let me tell you
more about this
and how we try to make our
obligations as data processor.
But first of all, people
are very important.
So we are really proud to
say that we have the world's
foremost experts in
security, and they
are responsible for information,
application, and network
security as well.
They are the ones who
maintain our defense system,
build our security
infrastructure,
decide on the security
review process, also helping
with their review
process when we onboard
vendors, sub-processors.
And they are also the ones
who build Google's security
infrastructure and
responsible for implementing
Google's security policies.
But we also have a
very extensive team
of compliance
professionals and lawyers,
including privacy lawyers,
and our responsibility
as compliance
professionals is to assure
that Google as a
whole, the company,
are fully trained and
aware about the latest data
protection standards.
As an example, we design
Google's privacy training
program.
But we also have policy
and compliance experts
who directly engage with
the regulators in Europe who
are responsible for imposing
those really high fines.
And whenever we're developing
features for compliance,
we check with them
to make sure that we
are going in the
right direction,
and it can be helpful with our
customers' compliance needs.
So it's fair to say
that we are really
committed having customers
in their GDPR compliance.
And we're not only saying this,
but we put our commitments
to writing.
As an example, we updated our
data processing agreements
with new terms that reflect
the changes within the GDPR.
And here, I wanted to
remind you that in case you
haven't done so, please opt
in to the most recent data
processing amendments.
And I will show in
two slides later
how you can do that if you
haven't done so by tuning
into our GDPR Resource Center.
We also state in our
data processing agreement
how we, as data processors,
only process data
based on your instructions.
Also, our employees are
required to sign confidentiality
agreements.
And they have to go through
mandatory privacy trainings.
This is what we, the
privacy professional,
designs and also makes sure
that every single person
in the company
goes through them.
Our employees also
have to go through code
of conduct training,
and that training
explains the best practices
and expected behavior
for data protection.
So what do we do specifically,
besides the contracts, when
we assist the data
controllers, you the customers,
in GDPR compliance?
As I mentioned,
data subject rights
are incredibly important
under the GDPR.
And under the GDPR,
you have to prepare
for data subject requests to--
they will ask to access,
rectify, and restrict
their data processing.
And we do have built-in
functionality and products
where these requests
can be easily met.
We also have a
dedicated team who
can respond in case
you have any data
protection-related enquiry.
We had turned on
incident notifications
for several years, so
it's nothing new to us.
And we continue to
promptly notify them
when we become aware
of an incident.
And this is very
important under the GDPR,
because the GDPR has really
strict incident notification
timelines.
For data controller,
for the customer,
it's 72 hours after you
became aware of an incident.
And within this
72 hours, you have
to notify the
supervisory authorities.
Us data processors,
on the other hand,
we have to notify
you, the controller,
without undue delay.
And again, you can find
all these terms in our data
processing amendments.
And as I mentioned,
I really want
to call your attention to
our GDPR Resource Center,
which you can very easily
find by Googling GDPR, Google,
and Resource Center.
And on the top banner, as I'm
showing you on this slide,
you can see where you can click
and opt in to the new terms.
And please do so to
make sure that you
have an agreement which
reflects the GDPR changes.
On this website, you can
also find more details
about the things
I described today,
including some of
the product features
I'll describe at the end.
So number two, use
of sub-processors.
Today's business environment
is a little more complex
as having just one
data controller
and one data processor.
And we, Google,
as well, in cases,
rely on third-party vendors
processing customer data.
And it's very important that
these third party vendors
go through very, very rigorous
security and selection process.
And even the onboarding
process is very, very rigorous.
And for example, they have
to go through strict security
testing.
We are also transparent about
the sub-processor we use.
You can find them
on our website,
and also, there is a link in
the data processing agreement
where you can review
the list of them.
Data subject rights
is a third point.
And I decided to use two
specific data subject
rights to demonstrate
how we in G Suite
can support in case customers
come to you with data subject
requests.
The first one is data return.
So I mentioned at the beginning
that there are new data subject
rights under the GDPR.
And one was one of them is
right to data portability.
What does it mean?
Data subjects, these have
directives as their data
even before they GDPR.
But the GDPR takes
it even further.
It requires that
the data controllers
have to make this data
available to customers
in a machine-readable structure
in a commonly-used format.
They should be able to
export it and transmit
to another controller
if they wish,
without any further hindrance
from the controller.
Now, Google had that
feature even before the GDPR
that made it available
both for our customers
to retrieve their data, export
it, and take it to somewhere.
It's called Google Takeout.
And also in G Suite,
the administrators
were able to export customer
data via the functionality of G
Suite.
But for GDPR, we
took it even further,
and we recently,
before the GDPR,
launched an enhanced
data export feature
that enables you to download
data for all of your domain.
And we made sure that
you can do it securely,
so we added the additional
security controls in there.
As an example, only super admins
who have been with the company
for 30 days can do that.
They have to use
additional authentication,
multi-factor authentication.
Whenever there is
multiple super admins,
we promptly notify them if
such export was initiated.
And also, you can
only do this if you
have less than 1,000 employees.
Otherwise, we have to go
through the Google Support Team,
and they can temporarily
enable the feature, again,
to make sure that the data
export happens securely.
The next one is data deletion.
Data deletion is not
a new right in GDPR,
but it is still very important.
Because we want
to make sure that
we only store data until
its necessary for business
purposes.
So we always had
built-in functionality
in G Suite and all
of its products
that made it possible for you
to delete customer data anytime.
And we also, as we mentioned
also in our data processing
amendment and also in a
recent public statement,
we make sure that relevant
customer data, in case we
receive a deletion
request from you,
it will be deleted from
our system within 180 days,
unless, of course, there are
some retention obligations
that apply.
And this can be a EU member
state's law requirement
or a litigation hoard or tax
authorize this sometimes also,
wants us to retain data
longer, as an example.
And now, the fun.
So probably when you heard first
about the GDPR in the news,
you read about the
incredible fines.
The fines under the GDPR
are incredibly high.
No other data
protection legislation
could impose such incredible
fines as the GDPR,
and whenever you need
attention from more executives
at your company, I recommend
you to bring up the fines.
That always gets
their attention.
And the fine, of course,
can be, as maximum fine,
20 million euros, or 4%
of the annual turnover.
The GDPR gives example, what
are the scenarios and what
are the type of infringements
these maximum fines
can be imposed?
And these are related to the
data protection principles
I mentioned at the
beginning, data subject
rights or international
data transfer mechanisms.
And the GDPR also
gives a detailed list
of what are the
deciding factors,
the data protection
authorities that
can impose these
fines are looking to,
and things that can be
relevant, the type of data
that was [INAUDIBLE]
for the infringement.
These are sensitive
persona data, for example.
It also depends
on your behavior.
Was the infringement the
result of a negligent
or an intentional behavior?
Did you have any similar
relevant previous
infringements?
How much did you do to
mitigate the damage that
resulted from the infringement?
How much did you cooperate
with the data protection
authorities?
So these are all deciding
factors, and there is more
in the GDPR in Article 83.
And finally, as a
fifth point, I wanted
to talk about the
GDPR and security,
because GDPR is a
data protection law,
so it has privacy and
security provisions as well.
Such as other things,
the GDPR has provisions
and describes responsibilities
both for the data controller
and the data processor.
So you and the customer and
us are both responsible.
And security is really
at the core of the GDPR.
The GDPR doesn't give you an
exhaustive list of product
features that you must have
in order to be GDPR compliant,
and, well, it would be
very difficult because
of the changing technology.
But it does describe
that you have to--
both the controller and the
processor have to perform
a risk assessment based on
the recent state-of-the-art
industry-accepted best
practices in security.
And actually, the
GDPR does bring up
two examples, [INAUDIBLE]
and encryptions
as some of these best examples.
But really, the
point is that you
have to be able to
protect your user
data from unlawful access,
unauthorized access,
and unlawful processing.
So what are some
of these examples
we have in G Suite that you can
leverage in GDPR compliance?
I want to talk
about these features
in the context of access
monitoring and access
control, because these are very
important for your security
best practices.
And again, I've highlighted
the encryption here,
because the GDPR does
highlight encryption as one
of the examples of
security best practices.
The first one is
two-step verification.
Why do companies need
two-step verification?
Well, we know that passwords
can be easily compromised.
They can be figured out.
They can be stolen.
So it's very important
that, especially
in terms of enterprise
corporate data,
which is more
vulnerable in terms
of security vulnerability--
the two-step verification
gives you an additional layer
when it asks users
when they sign in
for additional proof
of identification.
And one good example
is a security key,
a physical security
key that you can
plug into your laptop,
monitor, or desktop.
So this is definitely
highly recommended.
We use this.
All employees of Google
are required to use it
as a security best practice.
Suspicious login monitoring--
so suspicious logging
and monitoring uses
Google's robust machine
learning capabilities to
detect suspicious logins.
And in order to use
this, administrators
can sign up for email alerts.
And we look at possibly
suspicious behavior examples.
For example, if
someone tries to log in
to your corporate account
from an unusual location
or from a new unknown
device, first the process
is, in most cases, we send a
login challenge to the user.
And we typically ask them--
we send them a passcode
that they have to enter.
We send them a passcode in email
or either cell phone, whichever
was their selected method.
And if they're unable to solve
this challenge or avoid it,
then this is when we send
a very clear notification
to the administrator so
that it can take an action--
or he can take action.
Mobile Device Management, MDM--
so we recently
launched a feature
that we announced the next
terms of MDM, mobile device
management, as part of or
Cloud Identity SSO catalogue.
And this is great,
because now, basic MDM
comes by default on [INAUDIBLE]
corporate mobile devices.
And that means that
employees don't
have to download additional
profiles in order to use this,
but it comes by default both
on Android and iOS devices.
It helps the
administrator, because it
gives a single dashboard view
where the administrator can
see all the devices that
can access corporate data.
It makes it very easy to enforce
passcodes or remove content
or wipe devices remotely in
case they get compromised.
And again, the great
thing about this
is that no user
intervention needed,
and this is very helpful
in today's world.
Especially when
corporations have
to deal with the [INAUDIBLE]
of the devices, for example,
the solution works really well.
And of course, as I mentioned,
it comes with the basic MDM
feature by default,
but you can always
select more advanced settings.
Data Loss Prevention, or DLP--
DLP uses Optical Character
Recognition, or OCR,
technologies to scan
content in Gmail,
including its
attachments, files,
and in Drive and Team Drives.
And it's looking for
possibly sensitive content.
We privacy professionals
are aware of what
can be potentially
sensitive data
both globally and
country-specifically.
As an example, we know that
credit card information
and bank account
information is sensitive,
so we have these, by
default, turned on.
And you can very easily turn
these predefined detectors
on and off, depending on which
countries you operate in,
for example.
You also define your
own custom rules,
because you are the one
who knows your business.
You are the one who knows what's
sensitive data for you in terms
of intellectual property
and sensitive project codes.
And you can find these
rules by keywords
or using regular expressions.
And if you observe
that you receive
too many false positives, you
can always adjust these content
thresholds.
Information rights management
is a next good example.
We do have it available both
for admins within the admin
console and users.
And what it means is that the
admins can limit file access
privileges.
For example, you
may want to restrict
certain sensitive files and
make sure that they can only
be shared within the domain.
And it gives you
greater control,
so you can define different
rules for teams, for example.
The sales team, as
an example, are not
allowed to share certain type of
files with an external domain.
And it also adds IRM controls,
additional information rights
management controls both
for the admin and the user.
And here, I am
showing how it looks
from the user perspective.
So first of all,
by default, it's
only shared by the
user who created it.
And they have to take additional
actions, additional clicks
if they want to
share it with others.
And also, again, both
administrators and user are--
can very easily, by
checking checkboxes,
can disable downloading,
printing, and copying files.
And finally, I wanted to talk
about enhanced email security.
Gmail now offers S/MIME.
And S/MIME stands for
Secure/Multipurpose Internet
Mail Extension.
And this is why we
prefer to call S/MIME.
And really, secure is
an important word here.
So this is now the
industry standard way
of encrypting e-mails.
And it requires e-mails
to be signed and encrypted
when then they send it out.
And it's also important that you
can bring your own certificates
and use that with S/MIME.
But Gmail has additional
security features,
such as TLS and DKIM warnings.
And I show an
example here that we
try to give very, very
clear visual signals in case
we suspect that a user
receives a message
from an unauthenticated source.
And also, we try to give very
clear visual signals if we see
that a message was unencrypted.
So this was the last
security feature
I wanted to talk about today.
But of course, there are more.
And you'll find some
of these features
both for G Suite and GCP at
our GDPR Resource Center.
So please stay tuned for Q&A.
We'll be back in less than a
minute.
Hi.
Welcome back.
We received some questions
that I would like to answer.
The first question is
an interesting one.
Does the GDPR require data
to be stored in the EU, data
localization?
So one great thing about
the GDPR, that it does not
require data localization.
It does enhance the
data transfer mechanism,
so it does require that
there is an adequate level
of data protection
from data that's
flowing outside of the EU.
And the GDPR lists
certain mechanisms
how this can be achieved
or recognized by DPAs.
And some of these are the
privacy shared, for example,
or [? model ?] contract
clauses that Google uses.
And GDPR mentions other
mechanisms as well,
for example, binding
corporate rules,
and you can have
certification as well.
But this is very important.
So as the EU, for
the European Union,
actually, it's aimed to make
sure that the data flows freely
within the EU, so there are no
data localization requirements.
The second question is, will
all these security features
be used only for EU citizens?
I've got this question before.
It's a very good question.
And as someone who worked
on these privacy programs,
we really do not
differentiate between EU
citizens and other
citizens when we have
been preparing for the GDPR.
So we make these features
available to everyone,
because we believe these
are-- the GDPR has great data
protection practices.
We believe that data subject
rights are important.
We agree with all the data
protection principles.
So we really want to make
sure that the good things that
came with GDPR are
available for everyone.
The third question is about
the GDPR Resource Center,
and I have been talking about
the Resource Center a lot.
So again, it's very easy to find
just by Googling GDPR, Google,
and Resource Center.
But we will provide a link
in the platform on the Q&A
session.
Someone was asking how can
they find out more about DLP.
We have white paper,
help center articles.
And those are good
examples, again.
And if I remember correctly,
you can actually find these.
Again, just to go to the
GDPR Resource Center.
And when we talk about
product features that
can be helpful with the
GDPR, they are linked there.
But again, you can also
just Google DLP or Data Loss
Prevention white paper.
And both the actual white paper
and other help center articles
will pop up.
And same goes for GCP.
You can learn about DLP
API for GCP as well.
OK, so the last
question is, is there
a continuity between GDPR
compliance in G Suite and GCP?
What are the counterparts in
the larger Cloud offering?
Which features you presented
are also available in GCP?
It's a great question.
Yes, there is a continuity
between GDPR compliance
within G Suite and GCP.
I am in G Suite, but
we work very closely
with the GCP teams.
And they have similar
features-- not exactly the same,
because the product
offering is different.
But they also have,
as an example,
a two-step verification for
the DLP, Data Loss Prevention.
They have DLP APIs.
They also offer various
products for access monitoring
and control.
Some of them are
product-specific.
For example, they have
Stackdriver monitoring
and logging, Cloud security
scanners, I believe,
[INAUDIBLE],, and also
Security Command Center.
So I actually didn't go through
all the security features,
because there are many.
But we have Google Security
Center and Google Command
Center for G Suite
and GCP, which
is very helpful for
the administrators,
because it can give them an
overall view of the G Suite
products and
security positioning.
So those are very helpful.
And in case I don't
remember all of them,
again, these product
features and more are
available in the
GDPR Resource Center.
So I don't know if we
have more questions, but--
nope?
So we don't have more questions.
So again, I wanted to tell you
that we do these live webinars
every Tuesday.
You can check it on the
Cloud on our website.
And we have a nice
session coming up.
And stay tuned for
it-- this is a CE Chat,
Observability with OpenCensus.
And thank you so much
for joining in today.
[MUSIC PLAYING]